[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in tom pelicero he's
covering the uh the senior bowl nfl
network provides live coverage of that
it's saturday at 2 30 eastern this kenny
pickett hand sized tom i mean it's worth
bringing you on just to talk about it i
mean how controversial is this at the
senior bowl
dan i think we've got one uh hand sized
story every year with the quarterbacks
in the nfl draft you remember a couple
years ago
joe burrow at the combine after his
measurement tweeted something along the
lines of i've decided to retire from
football because the ball's going to
slip out of my my tiny baby hands
uh you know with kenny pickett it's kind
of a unique deal because you know yes i
had heard the same thing people were
curious about his hand size which is
pretty standard especially when a guy
wears gloves on the field that's always
a tell that makes makes scouts think uh
this guy might not have particularly big
hands what i didn't know until i sat
down with pickett uh the first thing
yesterday morning here in mobile was
he's got
double jointed thumbs so his thumb
actually kind of if you think about
pressing your thumb into the palm of
your hand that's kind of like the
resting position for him it obviously
doesn't impact him throwing the football
but if you're talking about splaying out
your hand and measuring it from thumb to
pinky you might get potentially short
chains in your measurement so he did not
get his hand measured here but you know
his explanation was pretty simple which
is i'm gonna you know do some extra
exercises you know basically roll the
thing out which is something that
quarterbacks do as silly as it sounds
you roll out your hand
uh to make sure that you're getting you
know close to nine inches and he'll get
an accurate measurement at the combine
in a month or so
but is this a big deal for some teams
well it's it's a consideration you know
i think especially for the cold weather
teams you always hear that in colder
weather it can be harder to grip the
football if you've got you know smaller
hands uh everybody would love to have a
bread far ten and a quarter inch meat
hook but as long as you're on the plus
side of nine inches generally that's
going to be uh sufficient for teams now
if somebody measures in well below the
line just like any other measurable if
your your height your weight your speed
whatever is just so far below the line
uh that's going to raise some questions
but again we've seen guys with with not
huge hands uh have success
in the nfl uh you know there's guys like
baker mayfield they're smaller
quarterbacks who have huge hands you
know is that save baker mayfield from
ever fumbling in cleveland no you know
is it the the end-all be-all it's one of
many traits but it's it's always an
interesting one to uh hone in on it at
these times a year all right help me
understand you uh reported harbaugh's
gonna go visit the vikings tomorrow help
me understand
like
you have national signing day and
it's like
they're let michigan's letting him go
flirt with somebody to see if he or they
fall in love together i i'm just i'm
trying to find the logic in this from
michigan's side of this and maybe even
jim harbaugh
well jim harbaugh if you go back a year
dan took a pretty substantial pay cut on
his new deal uh he was one of the i
believe one of the lower paid power five
uh coaches making in the four million
dollar range last season then he ends up
making a a run to the college football
playoff so there was always going to be
some sort of a reckoning that happened
after the season contract-wise whether
that was michigan you know boosting him
up into that 10 million range that most
of the top coaches are at or uh jim
doing what he's done
over the past several months now which
is you know really since uh michigan
clinton spot in the playoff and they had
their you know that whatever it was
several week gap he was in touch with
nfl people those rumors started in
december and one of the people that
harbaugh is close to in the nfl now is
crazy adolfo mensah who is the vikings
new general manager harbaugh gave him
his first job uh back in 2013 in san
francisco when adofo mensah was a he was
a commodities trader and they hired him
as an analyst with the 49ers they
developed some type of relationship
during that time and so the expectation
within the league was that uh if
harbaugh got a job adopted would
probably come with him well now you've
got the flip scenario where uh quasi's
in minnesota
he's a big supporter of jim harbaugh
they reached out they got permission to
speak with him gage's interest on
saturday and it's now pushed to the
point that the plan is for harbaugh to
fly into minnesota and interview on
wednesday i mean until harbaugh actually
gets to the vikings facility dan i feel
like there is
some level of uh george costanza driving
to the poconos thing going on here where
it's like i'm really gonna do it guys
i'm really gonna go to the nfl and you
just wonder you know what potentially
could happen but we're 24 hours away
from that being a real thing i mean it's
absolutely consideration for the vikings
they interviewed kevin o'connell again
yesterday he's in the mix patrick graham
the giants defensive coordinator is in
minnesota today
those are really your finalists at this
stage but you would think if harbaugh
sets foot on that plane he's doing it
with the intention to try to get a deal
done in minnesota but i'm trying to also
understand the dolphins here because if
stephen ross doesn't want to take
harbaugh away from his alma mater
but if he knows harbaugh wants to go
back to the nfl
he doesn't want harbaugh to go to the
vikings he would want him to go to the
dolphins wouldn't he
you would certainly think that and
stephen ross you're right i mean that's
that's this has been going on for you
know basically since jim harbaugh got to
the university of michigan which was
people asking steven ross if he was
going to hire him and ross who has his
name on practically every building in
ann arbor uh you know repeatedly saying
he wasn't going to be the one to bring
him back absolutely the the dynamic
changes when it becomes real but you
know i would tell you um you know many
of us have chased this throughout the
week the possibility that
um you know they could that the dolphins
could get in the mix for jim harbaugh to
this point uh
personally substantiated that that is a
front burner uh thought for them right
now they've got interviews later this
week with mike mcdaniel 49ers offensive
coordinator and kellen moore the cowboys
offensive coordinator uh you know those
two guys are squarely in the mix and
based on these next 48 to 72 hours
exactly how this plays out
great stuff as always tom thank you we
appreciate your time
thank you that's tom pelosero nfl
network insider
checking on hand size of the senior ball